welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day six and
we're gonna learn the environment for
success habits of
billionaires enjoy
[Music]
people don't always like you and they're
not always happy for you
and if you surround yourself with people
who are not
accustomed to your success
they become fearful they become scared
because you are reflecting back
something to them that they don't
recognize
now they're not going to say
you know i'm very fearful
because you're reflecting back to me
something i don't recognize
they're going to say you know what
they're going to say
they're going to say who she thinks she
is
who she thinks she is that only happens
when you are around people who do not
mean
and want and aspire to the best
for you people who want the best for you
want you to be your best so my greatest
advice to you
is to surround yourself with people who
are going to
fill your cup until your cup runneth
over
so when people say you're so full of
yourself you can say
[Music]
yes i'm full
i'm so full my cup runneth over
and to know that once your cup runneth
over
you cannot spend your life
with your gallon size
offerings offering them to pint-sized
people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you have got to surround yourself with
gallon-sized people
who can hang in the same company with
you
so that you're not offering your gallons
to those little pipes out there
who can't hold it anyway you need a team
around you to deliver a lot of idea how
do you choose your team
based on what
well um i suppose honestly that
it tends to be gut feel more than
anything else um
so when i interview somebody
my interview question is always the same
it's just
i said tell me the story of your life
and and the decisions that you made
along the way and why you made them
and then um
if and and also tell me about some of
the most difficult problems you worked
on
and how you solve them and
that that question i think is very
important because
the people that really solve the problem
they know
exactly how they solved it they know the
little details
and the people that pretended to solve
the problem they can maybe go one level
and then they get stuck elon you've
you've been compared to henry ford
richard branson
you know steve jobs uh who do you
compare yourself to
um and i don't really compare myself to
anyone um i mean it's not
um i mean there's certain people that i
admire from history that i think are
you know i think are great um so
certainly many of the
scientists and engineers and literary
figures and so forth
um and uh like i'm a big big fan of
ben franklin you know he was a scientist
and sort of thinker and
yeah i mean he was kind of guys who did
did what needed to be done you know so i
like guys like that i
right i wouldn't say i compare myself in
any way but i certainly admire them
we all get um gifts uh
we get certain things in our life that
are um
that we're very lucky about and one of
the most powerful one is who your early
role models are
you know you could they could be it was
your grand grandfather it was in a big
sense
my mom and dad but my grandfather too
and you know i had my mom had me when
she was
uh 17 years old and she was still in
high school
in albuquerque new mexico and this is in
1964. i can assure you that
being a pregnant uh teenager in high
school was not
cool in albuquerque new mexico at that
time
and uh so it's in
in so it was a very it was difficult for
her
my grandfather went to bat for her when
they tried to kick her out of school and
you know he
they're they're incredible i had so the
gift i had is i had this incredible
family
you will move in the direction of the
people that you associate with so i
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself and
actually the most important decision
many of you make not all of you will be
the spouse you're choosing
and uh you really
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be
you'll move in that direction and the
most important person by far
in that respect is your spouse i can't
overemphasize how important that is and
you're right
the friends you have uh they will form
you as you go
through life and
make some good friends keep them for the
rest of your life but
have them be people that you admire as
well as like them
i was very lucky in life uh if you tell
me who your heroes are i will
make a pretty good prediction about how
what you're going to do and i i had the
right heroes i was very lucky in life
and my heroes never let me down and
started with my dad
and then i had others in business and so
i have had
great teachers some formal teachers some
that were just
informal teachers teachers by instinct
or example
and if i hadn't had those
uh you know my life i'm sure would have
been very different
i always believe in i love the the the
um
you know i love that thing of
collaborating you taking the best of
what you do
and someone taking the best of what
you're doing you're not robbing from
what they do and then
robbing from what you do and y'all bring
the best of what you are to the table
and you
put it in this mix and you see what
happens you know i love that part of
uh creating so there'll definitely be uh
you know
because i i don't believe in those lines
that people put up for music
you know this is for this person this is
for that people you know this is rock
this is blues i just believe good music
bad music and
you know put those two elements in the
room and you know
see what happens that that the you know
god the universe the movement whatever
it
whatever happens in in that room tonight
we
not we why whatever happens
you know make great music there's no
doubt
that uh you know creating a board
having people like dave marquart there
who
wasn't at the company you know and we
were so overwrought about
you know this is right this is wrong we
messed this up that
having people have a little bit of
distance uh
come in and talk to us is good you know
for the last
uh oh 30 years or so
i've gotten to be friends with warren
buffett and he
he's in omaha uh he's not in this tech
world at all
you know and to him it's like hey how
could you ever know which
will rise and which will fall i'm not
going to put money
uh until apple sold at a multiple of 12.
then
he decided he could put 50 billion into
that
after he asked all his friends hey you
know if the if somebody had an
uh iphone that was half as expensive
would you switch away
you know or is it more like jewelry
where you really want uh
to to have an iphone and so he decided
that
the those profit streams might not be
eliminated anytime soon anyway he
because he's not
in this world he has a
a a definite way of looking at things
including this idea of how
work should be fun he has made his work
so much fun
that he works more hours than i do
he works six days a week at 88 years old
and he likes to say that he skips to
work every day he he doesn't but
he says that when he was 83 he could
still skip but now he's done
really he can't do it so
having somebody like that you know the
toughest thing i went through was this
anti-trust lawsuit
where you know it didn't seem uh very
predictable
and he was a great counsel during all of
that stuff so getting somebody who's
in successful in another domain
but yet kind of a business uh type
mindset anyway for me that that was a
huge gift
i do think that if you want to talk
about software innovation
that at least listening to the ideas of
people who've been successful in that
area
isn't such a bad thing i mean you could
you literally say
that we can't talk to politicians if you
really think
that sharing our opinions about say
climate change or
malaria or malnutrition or charter
schools
you know if that's really bad uh you
know this group
does have more free time they have
proven
that you know their energetic consul can
solve some things
and often they get into a phase of their
life like steve schwartzman is putting a
lot of his
energy and thought into very creative
and i think what will be uh positively
impactful philanthropy
there are probably a lot of people who
can who can run microsoft and do a
reasonable job
when i was growing up bill gates was my
my hero oh come on
yes he's like darth vader he's not he's
not luke skywalker
he's the bad guy no he is not um bill
gates
ran one of the most mission-driven
companies that i can think of
right and you know right now i think
microsoft their mission is less focused
than it used to be
but when i was thinking about you know
what i wanted to be when when i grew up
you know microsoft i thought had
had a great mission put a computer on on
every desktop
and in every office right or maybe it
was every desktop and every home
uh but and you know i mean there are
companies that define themselves by a
way of doing things right i mean there's
um them like the hp way that i was
talking about and there are companies
that define themselves by making a
concrete change in the world
and um you know microsoft did that
and i like i have a huge amount of
respect for for him for doing that he
pushed them and
it was an incredibly inspiring company
um during the time that he was doing
that i think that they're they still are
doing a lot of things but i think that
they've lost some of the focus
and um i don't know i mean i think he's
like one of the one of the greatest
visionaries that our that our industry
has ever had
i always kind of like i get a little
upset whenever
any media attention focuses on me
personally
and me leaving facebook much less a
movie
it's been it's been kind of a bad year
hasn't it
it turned out okay time academy it
turned out it turned it turned out great
the time thing was awesome
um the um that was those really
flattering but like
but i think that it's one of these
things that the media systematically
gets
wrong is that this idea that it's a
person right it's never a person
right it's always a team and the most
important thing if you
are an entrepreneur trying to build
something is you need to build a really
good team
and that's what i spend a lot of my time
on right i mean i spend
probably at least three hours a day with
our core team
right at doing things i spend probably
25 percent of my time recruiting finding
good people
both outside the company and inside the
company to put in more
and more impactful roles i'm sergey
britt
i'm from google and prior to that
i was a phd student at stanford larry
and i first met when he
came to visit during the the phd
recruitment weekend which was
he started a couple years after i did
and uh
we became good friends uh when when he
actually
agreed to join and came on board and
we experimented with a variety of things
you know we had some shared interest
and uh larry had this crazy idea that he
was going to download all the links on
the web and then
do something with them it wasn't uh
entirely clear what
we did find that there were great
applications
and one of them was search which
eventually became google co-founders are
super important for
uh building a company and you guys are
doing great for 15 years
have you sort of like fundamentally
disagreed on something at all
over over the last 15 years and how did
you how do you resolve
where do i start
no i think if you
get to know somebody over a long period
of time we're working together for so
long and we
you know are committed to doing that you
don't like get
agitated about one little thing or the
other i don't know we
work it through and also generally we've
gotten
to think uh remarkably alike
which scares some people around us i
guess yeah and the other thing i mean we
know enough i guess
that when we're disagree i mean you make
a lot of calls that aren't obvious so i
mean if you're disagreeing it's probably
that it's
not obvious what to do is part of the
interviewing process do you have
essentially a culture check
like that yes but not like a checklist
culture is always something that we
interview for
of kind of curiosity and and uh you know
it's easy to find people who say
oh i read the netflix culture deck i
love it i really want to be there
you know what's harder is well you know
what are the main things you disagree
with and why
you know and when we get a blank stare
we're like okay not really a first
principle thinker
and when they say um well i thought the
way that
uh you didn't talk about how to
acculturate and
you know if i'm not great in day three
am i out you know or
is there um you know do you look at it
like a
athlete where it's over some you know
time period to prove yourself and if so
what's that time period
and why haven't you clarified that then
we're like oh yeah that's a good insight
first principle thinker so we're looking
for people who
you know are curious um typically
self-confident
and they're not um they're questioning
everything around them if you're going
to politics you go to dc
if you go into finance new york movies
probably still la
and tech is silicon valley silicon
valley has an aspect that's
that's very open very fluid and
and it helps tremendously on these
cutting edge ideas you want to be in the
place where you can talk to as many
people
as possible about your ideas because
that's the way you will
know that they're cutting edge and you
will improve them even more
i made the mistake in my life of
studying people that
appeared to be successful a lot of
people are like that
they appeared to be successful you know
today today in the the the
the times that we live in you know you
can go on instagram it looks like
looks like everybody owns a ferrari
everybody has a rolls royce
everybody looks like they're having the
best day of their life
that's that's not studying that's
watching i want to study people
or even even at conferences you can go
to a conference and watch somebody on
stage
and he could he he or she could present
to like they're so successful but
if you really get behind the scenes
you'll find out there is no success
there it's just a lot of talking
and so i would just strongly suggest to
people to
pick a handful of people and make sure
those people are actually
doing not just saying
you know that they're they're not
talking about success they're actually
doing success every day
and how would you know what they're
doing well you should you would you
would see it in their statistics right
like there's some things you can't fake
yeah you can't fake somebody
uh we're buying 250 million worth of
real estate this month
with my money hard to fake that okay
it's a great instagram post by the way
but you can't fake it there's going to
be a loan
there's going to be a building there's
going to be you know acres and acres of
land there's going to be
people living there like you just can't
fake it so there's a lot of things you
can fake
you know you can make a nice little
quote put it on instagram
people look at it like that's the truth
you know and and uh
the public is is confused with a lot of
what appears to be the truth
it's not that's right and so i would
just tell people
um study people
that have success that are doing it now
also the second thing i would say is
make sure that where you're getting your
advice from them
lines up with where you need advice
right so
warren buffett you know warren buffett
he he's at the
he's at the he's at the tail um
he he's at the tail of his of his
he's probably here right so
here he was doing different things than
he's doing here he he talks about
investing in stocks but he actually
doesn't do it
he doesn't buy stocks he buys companies
yeah uh so you gotta you gotta listen to
people steve jobs right here was one of
the most aggressive
business people that this plan has ever
seen i mean he was barbarian
aggressive so was bill gates but if you
talk to bill gates today
bill and steve steve's not alive
obviously but bill gates today saying
dude i'm giving all my money away money
doesn't matter that's not what he was
saying right here
25 years ago i had three friends
my life has not always been this i had
three friends
one was a drug dealer
one was my girlfriend who didn't love me
she loved the drug dealer more than she
loved me
she loved the drugs she's still on drugs
today
and my third friend couldn't be a friend
to himself much less to me
i had three friends in my entire life
i was the black sheep of my family five
kids
everybody in my household was worried
about grant
everybody my two sisters my brother
my mother were convinced
i would end up in prison or i would end
up dead
i should not be here today
so at 25 i recommitted to my education
but this time i started studying not
things that were in books but people
that it actually
created wealth not people that had made
money but people that he created wealth
this is completely different
i was no longer studying accounting and
economics i was studying
wealthy people and only wealthy people
i'm not talking about the doctor
that was a neighbor that makes a million
dollars a year and he's working 18 hours
a day and he hates his job
right he's working seven days a week he
can't ever spend time with his family
i'm talking about the yacht people
i'm talking about the people that are
spending as much time as they want on
vacation
i'm talking about the car dealer that
had uh 28 car dealerships
or 82 car dealerships that has
indisposable money and i quickly
realized something
that the wealthy people had financial
freedom and no one else did
okay a very small percentage of people
lots of people have money
my uncle had millions of dollars he was
terrified about his money
wouldn't spend it acted like a miser
buried money in the backyard
i realized my parents had it wrong the
information i had that was wrong
i started comparing the wealthy people
to what my dad did my dad worked every
day
every day of the week if he wasn't
working at the office he was working in
the yard
they saved money they cut their own
grass okay uh we ate all our food we
turned the lights off we didn't waste
anything and that was uncertainty
it was insecurity and it was fear and it
perpetuated uncertainty insecurity and
fear
and and all the lessons about money
money doesn't grow on trees a penny
saved is a penny earned
eat all your food people are starving
okay
money money you don't waste it don't
play with it
all that creates insecurity and it's
incorrect i'm 19 years old and i run a
consulting firm
and uh right now i just tell you real
estate stuff and i have
only about 60 grand from what i've done
saved up yeah and do you think i need to
still wait till 100 grand if you pass
the real estate
how long you had 60 grand uh for just
like 12 months now yeah dude
like you got to get the other 40 bro
it's an arbitrary number i just made up
the number
it could be 110 it could be dude it's
just it's just
so you know first of all when you get to
100 to call me
and i'm gonna probably tell you hey man
you need to wait till you got 350.
but at least then you're gonna be like
you know what i i learned how to make i
learned how to not just make a hundred
save a hundred and put 100 away people
are investing too soon
you guys are investing three grand here
two grand over here a thousand bucks 500
you're walking away from it it's never
worth any money it's dumb
and you never create the discipline what
you end up with is a bunch of losses a
bunch of little losses
rather than knowing i have the
confidence that i can make money
set it aside protect it
right protect it like a kid
[Music]
right it's not going to get in a wreck i
don't lose it
i would do that first so was there an
age i didn't invest my my first
investment was five thousand dollars and
i blew it
and i'm like i'm not doing that again my
next investment's going to be big
where i'm going to watch it because if
it's big enough dude if your life
depends on it you'll get up in the
mornings and you'll watch it
so my next deal was 350 grand it took
three years to do it
all i did was save money save money save
money i put 350 grand in the deal
sold that deal for four million dollars
a four million dollar profit but every
last penny you had
i had i had one third of all my money in
that deal i had a million dollars
like a million one put 350 in my first
deal
30 days later put 450 in a second deal
90 days later
put all the rest of my capital 100 of
all my money
plus 90 grand in three real estate deals
those are the first three investments i
ever made
the first three or four investments i
made in my entire life
three of the four did the little one
didn't
[Music]
the little one couldn't work
it's impossible to work it was too small
what's it going to do
it's not going to do anything
it's like going into a casino and you
bet 15
right you get blackjack so what it's
still 15
the first thing you're going to say is
dude i should have bet everything
but you did shouldn't even be in there
i'm in san fran
stockton and pine right behind me
just walked out of my hotel to get a
sense of the city
you know i don't think people get out
enough
the best things that have happened to me
in my life was when i left my room
my house even the city that i lived in
and um i think we stay home too much
you know here i am beautiful san
francisco maybe get out
i'm like oh i don't know if i want to go
out it's probably cold out there looking
not even anybody out here
i think an amazing beautiful city
beautiful city some parts of it are
beautiful
and some parts of it are ragged out
urine in the street
homeless people can't find a place to
live it's so expensive to live here they
can't have a house
and then there's beautiful parts of it
and so so that goes with every city
right every place
but the the wonderful thing is that
i get i get to make a choice whether i
find the beauty here
or the problems here and then i get to
be part of the solution
just disregard everything don't throw it
down don't throw in don't help out
and the problems continue but i wouldn't
know any of that if i didn't get out my
damn house man
guys get out ladies
leave your house get out
okay go out into the world and see
what's there
even get get up early to do it
again the best things that have happened
to me in my life happened
outside my house oh my god it's
beautiful
i had to leave i've moved first my first
move was late charles
took me 29 years to leave home
i was terrified uh oh i'm on a ramp
i can't get off here i'm looking for the
starbucks
um hey in comments below
how many times have you moved i'd love
to know how many times you've moved
changed locations
and uh lake charles 29 years old
made my first move hey guys we're
starbucks
starbucks okay thank you my friend thank
you
thank you have a great day 29 years old
left the house moved to houston i was
terrified
i know somebody think oh man wearing
ain't scared of nothing i was so scared
to move
out of lake charles it was like one of
the most
terrifying things i've ever done in my
life once i got there i was like that i
don't even know what i was scared about
i moved there i'll tell you how chicken
i was
i moved there because the reason i
picked houston was because
my brother and two sisters were there
so i'm like all right in case no
in case i can't make one friend
i swear to god that's what i was
thinking in case i can't make a friend
um
at least i have my brother my sister
guys how's it going how you doing
see those guys had to live outside home
is outside for those guys
i lived there for uh i don't know two uh
three four five
five years maybe then i moved to la
jolla california
didn't know one person there
had the life man i had the life in la
jolla i mean it was unbelievable
i actually went there with a person a
girlfriend me and a girlfriend moved
there
i i i got i moved there
she left about a year later maybe two
years later
i had the the single man's life
you know what i mean in la jolla
i had it made i was i was loving life
and then i reached the point where i'm
like uh i need to grow up now
i need i i want a wife and i want kids
i'm on grant street look at that
uh i want a wife and kids and i knew
that that
person was not in ohio i'm talking to
you about moving i'm talking to you
about getting outside i'm talking to you
about leave man why have you been in one
spot
so long or maybe one spot you've been in
for ten years now you've moved once okay
i left i left la jolla moved to los
angeles california just so you guys know
nobody goes from what how you doing sir
nobody nobody moves from la jolla and
goes to l.a
people go from l.a to hawaii have a
great day huh
and uh say it again
oh thanks a lot appreciate it you guys
are my book now you see how would i meet
that customer if i hadn't left the house
this morning the hotel
would i do that that's crazy dude
got to get out got to get out went to la
lived in la for
i don't know 12 years had it made in l.a
had this
unbelievable house lionel richie's i'm
bragging
don't get me wrong i lived in lionel
richie's house
lionel wasn't there anymore so it's my
house now
i live there and and uh
all the parties were at my house it was
three quarters of an acre flat
lot in the hills above the sunset strip
doheny drive and oriole freaking
i mean spectacular place we had our
first two
k well we had our two kids there in the
house
all our friends had been there we got
married in that house i mean we were so
connected to that house it was
unbelievable
elena and i when we first saw the house
it was four times my budget
and i'm like we're buying that house and
you guys know how much i believe
that like how much i am against buying
houses
we fell so in love in that house in love
with each other
in love with the house in love with our
kids there in love with friends and
parties and memories and
and decorations and antique furniture we
love that house
and then it reached a time where i'm
like i think we got to leave
what we love we were so comfortable
there
sure enough five years ago i got up and
moved to miami we've been in miami five
years now
we travel all over the world we're
constantly moving i have 12 employees
i'm sure at one point you had you know
four or five employees
how did you go from four or five to
whatever you have i had
i had two employees from the age of
[Music]
29 no no from the age of 30
to 38 years old i had two employees
for eight years i did everything i was a
secretary
phone answer uh i did payroll
stole for myself did my taxes i did my
own taxes i wouldn't pay anybody
anything
okay from uh 32 to 38
38 to 45 i added like two or three
people
i was i was officing out of the guest
house
at my my my place that i lived at in in
los angeles
it's a big guest house it was a dude it
was an awesome hour lionel richie lived
in that house
you know it was a cool house right
but it was small thinking man i was
still thinking little
[Music]
and if you're going to stay small you're
going to get crushed so i'll push you
over the edge
2009 2008 and 2009.
so what eventually made you say you know
what i'm just going to make it
what happened was a guy told me years
before that
that vigor's not better and i believed
it
because he busted out he busted out when
he went big
and he says grant bigger's not better
man stay small and i
and i believed that dude and i carried
it on a long time it's bad advice
knowledge is power bad knowledge is too
so what i did was i stayed small until i
was 45 years old
five employees i was one of them so
four and um
when 2008 came i'm like this was stupid
dude like i got
a scale and and that was what 12
how many years ago was that nine years
seven or eight years ago
there was no jet there was no big office
it just shows you man when you change
your mind when you change your mind and
start like
hey i'm going to scale this thing out
i'm going to go global i'm going to have
people know me
i'm going to get attention i'm going to
get my products out i'm going to lower
my prices i'm going to bring this thing
to market i'm going to get big bring in
good people
we have how many employees we have now
charity 72 at the office
we got our partners here tonight we got
another 150 in
uh in in the real estate game we're
going to expand that we'll probably pick
up another 12 or 15 this month
because the two more deals we're
bringing on and next year i'm talking
about going global so
all everything that happened everything
has happened really good to us
it's happened because of the expansion
first get rid of the little think
and the old ideas and the middle class
mentality
[Music]
i'm gonna go to work i'm gonna save some
money i'm gonna put it in the bank i'm
gonna give it to the man
what's the bank dude the bank doesn't
even keep your money
they hate money cash is
it's trash cash is garbage it's pieces
of garbage paper
it is only useful when it is used
if you're taking notes they didn't teach
you this in school
this has been taught basic fifth grade
sixth grade
not in not when in high school or
college
cash this is a piece of paper okay it is
a piece of paper it's worthless
this is a piece of paper this actually
has more value
this piece of paper right here has more
value than this piece of paper right
here
why because one person has this piece of
paper
2 000 people have this data you
understand
this piece of paper right here is
useless though until it is used
let's find out if you got the little
thing how many believe
successes a mind game dude it starts
right here you got to fix this
you got to get rid of let's find out if
you've been affected
okay i want you to look at your
refrigerator at home
what's in it water
nothing's in it it's empty
it's very frugal of you let's buy a
refrigerator keep it empty
okay huh leftovers
what kind of leftovers what do you got
in there
a week old salad he opens the
refrigerator maybe tomorrow
i don't want to throw it away why
because his mother taught him that eat
all your food eat all your food eat all
your food how many of you brought up
like this three times a day
eat it all you're like five or six years
old eat it all
i'm full eat it anyway
eat it okay three peas left on your
plate eat them
eat them i'm done man i'm good
there's people starving in india
right dude you're being programmed right
now
okay if you're not going to eat them put
them in a little container
put them in the refrigerator tomorrow
okay and you go in the refrigerator
today you're 30 years later you got
little
ziploc containers with three wrinkled
peas
[Music]
okay you you got you got a coke can in
there it's got this much left in it
no fizz no fizz fit fizz has been going
10 days nobody's going to drink it but
you don't want to throw it away how many
of you got that refrigerator
oh you've been affected man how many of
you got a freezer and you got ice cream
that's been in there for three months
that much left
that much frost but it's ben and jerry's
i paid too much for that
what you doing buying ben and jerry's
anyway
okay how many of you read the book uh uh
the millionaire next door
live that book that book i read that
book that book made me
probably gonna make me a billionaire
okay i read that book i said i will
never be a millionaire
if i got to buy a used ford truck to be
a millionaire i ain't gonna be a
millionaire
and if i can't drink coffee every day i
don't want to be a millionaire that's
what i got from the book
i got from the book don't be a
millionaire
they worried about money every day okay
so you want to write this down
never take advice from a millionaire
ever they don't have any money
you guys think it's a lot of money how
many in the room
you have a net worth of over a million
dollars raise your hand let me
let me see your hands if you do okay
good now you guys need to share the word
here
that it's no money is it true or right
this is what's going to happen you're
going to end up with a million dollars
the millionaires never tell you this
you're going to end up with your first
million dollars
and you're going to go into fear oh sh
what do i do now
i can lose it see when you're broke
you got nothing to lose man you're out
there like let's go let's go let's
hustle it let's hustle it
let's go man hey man what you doing i
got nothing to lose
i'm dangerous you get a million dollars
you're like wait a minute
wait a minute i got to get a lawyer man
i got to get a i need to talk to my
accountant now
i need to get i need to get i need to
get merrill lynch
i need to get some experts i need to get
an llc
right i need to get protected and what
you do is you start going into
conservation mode
okay this is what i do i always stay
broke
i look at my cash accounts every day and
i try to get my cash accounts to zero
every day i want no liquidity
success is a contact sport you cannot be
successful if you don't make contact
you guys interview people and then you
never follow anybody up man nobody
follows anybody up
i spent i spent two million dollars with
a lawyer that's never called me back
same thing for the barber same thing for
the cosmetologist
same thing for the plumber same thing
for the roofer dude you guys don't call
people back because you think they're
not interested
do you think i'm only going to have one
car accident people that have one car
accident end up in three of them
okay divorcees god gets a divorce
everybody here knows somebody's got four
of them
but he ends up with four different
attorneys
like you guys don't follow up you are a
business not a lawyer
the chiropractor has the same problem he
goes and spends all this money on
equipment he knows how to do an
adjustment he doesn't know how to build
a business
the three things you can implement today
one you need to start thinking bigger
two you got to get your staff
on a program everybody must be on the
same page
you're trying to run a business the way
you would your marriage
problem is people gonna quit they're
gonna quit your business easier
because they don't know there's no
culture
and once you have those kids it's hard
to walk out on the marriage because you
can't get rid of the kids
the moment they turn 15 or 18 and they
leave you're like the marriage is over
same thing in a business man the
business falls apart every day you got
to train your people daily
as you're starting to take 10x global
you're trying to go to all these
countries you're trying to do all of
these things
like why why are you doing that yeah i
want to meet people man
i want to meet everybody yeah i want to
meet seven billion people yeah
i want to meet people in nigeria and i
want to meet people in singapore and i
want to meet people in africa and
i think these are my friends i just
don't know them yet mm-hmm you know i
want i want to make
i want to put these little anchor points
all over the planet so so that i have
friends my family
my my kids have friends all over the
world having money is one thing
but if you don't have anybody to to have
fun with
you know to have conversations with to
to
to mix it up with then you're just going
to be a whole lonely person
yeah see this is crazy like like for me
to
see as much as i use instagram and
facebook and youtube and snapchat and
all that stuff
what a lot of people don't see you guys
out there is like i still use
this walk over say hi to somebody walk
out be seen you still have to work the
physical universe
you can't just work a virtual universe
so
uh i could get you know 100 000 views
uh on uh
on a post but meeting one person face to
face and put him in my car to drive him
to an event
to his next appointment can be more
valuable than
than um than
118 000 people seeing a post on that
post yeah
instagram of me and mike tyson yeah that
one deal could be worth
hundreds of millions that one drive this
morning it could be worth
hundreds of millions of dollars you need
to filter down to who you listen to i
don't listen to a lot of people
yeah i mean i hear him you know but
you know he don't know what he's talking
about totally dude dude if you're not
saying that most of them has no clue
that's not clear
i'm not criticizing him by the way i'm
not criticizing
mike tyson yesterday telling me
something yeah he said i said that's
[ __ ]
mike yeah okay i mean who tells the
champ that's [ __ ]
i said dude you don't know what you're
talking about right now he's like
enlighten me man
tell me man i said all this surrender
[ __ ] dude it's all [ __ ]
the guy that told you you need to
surrender the therapist
that told you that [ __ ] was the
confused one
yeah okay so i i just i've learned who
not to listen to there's a way to make a
cold market warm
right you need a team you guys all of
you need a team
you're going to start with primerica
that you know the entry is cheap
it doesn't cost a lot to get involved
but you need a team
and and what happens is you can only
knock on so many so many doors
you can only make so many phone calls so
this is a mistake that i made when i was
uh 25 years old i i wanted to keep all
the money for myself but there was no
money
right i was making everybody needs to
understand grant
has not always been this guy flying in a
jet okay i was making 60 000
a year and trying to figure out how to
make another 10.
okay okay now i'll make 70. nothing
changed
your life doesn't change you got 10
grand left over what do you do with it
typically people spend it
that didn't change anything so i
wouldn't hire anybody i didn't have an
assistant i didn't have anybody doing
the stuff i didn't know how to do
nobody was loading up the crm nobody was
calling my customers i was one little
sales guy
i looked around me and there was a bunch
of other sales guys and none of them had
assistance
so i kept doing what these uh uh uh
ignorance people were doing
and then i looked at businesses what do
businesses do
oh they got assistance they got help
they got support they got phone lines
they got a business they got an office
right
so i'm like i got to get a company i
didn't need to go start my own business
i needed
an assistant okay i needed somebody else
making calls
i needed somebody to collab you need to
think you need to start thinking how
could you make 10 times more contacts
into that coal market
first thing you got to do is decide as a
business owner
do i want to make more money see see if
this dude this dude with the camera
if he shot if his if his pockets are
empty
he's walking around empty pockets
and he's got his fancy camera this is
the the problem with the artist
they starve their whole life they starve
their entire life
and then and then you wonder why they're
grumpy
there's no money i'm eating at littles
all the time sooner or later
sooner or later you hit the reality he
hits the reality i got a nice camera
i love taking photos i got to shoot
grant cardone
he watches lord sugar leave on his jet
and says hey why does he get to fly
free everywhere do whatever he wants and
i'm stuck with my camera
and no money how many believe that
sooner or later
sooner or later after days of going to
work months are going to work
years of going to work sooner or later
if he works for this man he's like
i resent this man i resent this man
i resent that man business owner i
resent paul mcfadden the business owner
i resent you
so i know i won't work for you in fact
what i'm going to do is screw things up
for you
it's called disengagement the only
business people that will survive
the only entrepreneurs that will make it
in business are those people
that decide to grow their businesses
little little will fail
not the little grocery store
okay if you try to stay small if you try
to stay small
you will fail okay i'm telling you this
from personal experience
i tried to stay small i tried to manage
the business
i tried to be the king of the business i
tried to have no
employees because employees cost money
i'm like
i'm not going to have any employees
i'm not going to pay the camera man i'll
just hire him when i do a gig
and the next time i'll hire another guy
and that'll keep my expenses low how
many are brought up like this
keep the expenses real low where we can
manage the expenses
the expenses are going to be so small
that that no matter how much we make
i keep it all people should be studying
the most successful companies in the
world
not not individuals don't worry about
dave or gary or tony or grant
what are successful people doing you
know i
one of the biggest mistakes i've made in
my life was tracking
people that were doing better than me
so what like like like i made so many
dumb ass decisions because uh dave did
it
or the millionaire next door that that
book
i don't want to be the millionaire next
door i want to know what jeff bezos is
doing i want to know what the boys at
google are doing
okay why why does a guy like mark
zuckerberg
go from college dorm room to one of the
richest
people on the planet that's who we
should be studying
and and don't listen to everybody else
because
those people have financial freedom to
the point to where they they can do
anything they want like you cannot
mess up some of these people's situation
they couldn't screw it up if they wanted
to
so uh the 10x rule is is a it says hey
look you want to scale to a point
to where you have the life you deserve
it's not about the money you want or the
money you need
scale your business so you can walk away
from it and money never stops taking
care of you and your family you don't
need to study
27 different words you study one more
and you're probably going to be good
most of us because of instagram and
facebook and youtube
we're listening to so many different
people
that that people do nothing this this is
the new crisis of our era
people are doing nothing not because
they're lazy because they have data that
is conflicting
so if you listen to dave dave says buy a
house then you listen to grant grant
says that's stupid
you're not going to do anything and if
you're never going to buy any real
estate hey go ahead and buy one house
yeah you're going to regret it later and
you're going to be like i wish i had
done what cardone said
but but you got to do something and what
you don't want to do is listen
to god and the devil because then you
get stuck in purgatory and you don't
have any fun at all
we look for compliance and willingness
before intelligence
[Music]
so you don't look for skill you look for
someone who's i don't look for potential
i never look for potential
what do you look for then just like yes
i'm willing to do look we hired the way
the patriots do
right you know they they don't hire the
best guys right
they never do they get all the rings
though they do
okay there's three people in charge on
that team there's not
33 it is a dictator
there's a dictator on that team if you
study all sports i mean it's pretty much
like that too
you know i mean portland portland
doesn't really have that you know he
they
he leaves curry alone and he leaves you
know um
durant durant alone and they're doing
good you know
that means it's a different style right
but but um
but somebody's those are with superstars
yeah man it's got to be so hard
yeah cause everyone's got a personality
you've got the opinion yeah
but so let's see how long that legacy
can last what are they three years now
yeah so you know let's see if they tear
themselves apart
but i know that new england patriots
thing works consistently there's an
owner
he's not involved he's trusted the coach
this guy bill runs the deal yeah
and then and then bill gives the ball to
brady and says a good
deal yeah you know so uh they hire they
they they they hire from the
lower half of the draft they don't
overpay for anybody
and if and if you don't comply you're
looking off the team they're going to
win without a great person
i like that there's 6 000 people in here
and another 5 000 people in another room
with pete vargas
okay there's 11 000 people that are
interested in changing
their financial condition
there's so much money on this planet
folks you have to keep remembering
surround yourself with people that are
telling you the truth
and the truth is there is so much money
on this planet
that everybody on this stream could be a
billionaire
is that real to you guys
i don't know if you're in the right
vehicle
i don't know if you have the right
mindset you probably don't have the
right customers yet
but jeff bezos thought about being a
billionaire
before he became a billionaire
okay uh elon musk
elon musk was not a baller
his whole life you're the asset
you are the one that is going to climb
the wealth mountain
you're gonna be the one okay i'm talking
to you right now
you are going to be the one eduardo
tanya tracy rana melissa
sigal rudolph you're the one that's
going to climb this thing
you're the one that's going to go from
the lower middle class
to the middle class to the upper class
to the wealthy
who who here has made a decision to get
to the top of the pinnacle
here's the deal about the decision folks
you need to make the decision
and then keep remaking the decision
you got bill gates warren buffett jeff
bezos jay-z and elon musk
they all know each other they've all
touched each other they all hang with
each other okay
collaborate collaborate with power
who do you want to hang with quit taking
what this
planet gives you quit taking your
neighborhood
okay i grew up in lake charles louisiana
i hated lake charles i got to tell you i
mean i'm grateful i grew up there i'm
grateful for my family i'm grateful for
the things i learned
but look once you go see the rest of the
planet you're like why am i living here
[Music]
why why is this all theirs go to
singapore
dubai sydney australia go to london go
to miami go to la find out where you
want to live where are the opportunities
where can you bust out and make it what
would you do
if you're a mountain climber you're
going to probably go visit
mount everest at some point
go where you need to go to get where you
need to get
[Music]
the rule of five who do you need to hang
out with collaborate with power
and then you want to write this down pay
to play
i had been told this most of my life i
did not trust it i was skeptical
the easiest way to collaborate with
power
is to buy a seat at the table these guys
over here i don't know if you guys can
pan over here can they see these guys
look at these guys look at these guys
these guys are spending three days with
me
i'll never forget yeah
i'll never forget these guys paid twelve
thousand dollars each to sit in that
chair
i look over there i'm like man they're
crazy people crazy
three days i gotta look at their ugly
faces
okay the reality is i don't know if
they're crazy or not
i know this to get to the top of that
pyramid folks how many believe this you
gonna have to do some crazy
[Music]
to stay where you are you will have to
do some crazy
listen to me to get to the top
you will have to do something crazy
to stay where you are you will be forced
to do something crazy
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series
give me a hashtag billionairemindset in
the comments below
so i can celebrate you raising your game
starts with raising your standards
raising your standards starts with
raising your environment
and raising your environment starts with
a decision
to make it so i just finished my
three-day workshop here in toronto where
i teach people how to become thought
leaders and transform them so they can
take the ideas that they have here in
their head
and blow it out to the world start
building a business making money having
an impact
and i was super fortunate to have two
people there at the workshop
who i've known for a decade plus friends
of mine who i've known for a long time
typically there's people who fly in from
around the world but i was really
grateful to have these two people
here and it was a really interesting
conversation that came out of it
from both of them and then that led to
my wife and other people who i've known
said over the last two years evan you've
really
turned it up a notch you you seem to
have access
a different level and and i want to know
how i can access that too
i know i felt it too i mean it's great
hearing it from these people who've
known me but but i know i felt it too
and maybe you guys have felt it too if
you watch back my videos that are two
three
five years old you've seen a shift
i'm still talking about believe a lot of
the message is exactly the same
but the confidence the standards the
expectations have gone up
in the videos i've gotten better i care
more
now how did that happen i'm not some
magical unicorn creature
you can do it too it happened because i
chose to
continue to surround myself with
excellence
with the videos i make my videos for me
the top tens that mentor me this year
like i make it for me
because i want to be around excellence
every day and here's what happens when
you're around people who are pushing the
limits
and doing amazing things every day
slowly it seeps into you it doesn't
happen on a daily basis
but it's a cumulative effect where if
you're around
steve jobs and ap giannini and well my
parents at howard schultz and kanye west
if you're around them every day
if they're talking in your ear every day
if you're watching the top tens and
mentor me every day
you're around it slowly it's gonna seep
into you the more you're around success
the more that success mindset will seep
into you
it just will and what that does is
change your perspective
and gives you more confidence and gives
you more courage
and that made me step up that made me go
and do things that otherwise i would
have been scared to do that made me go
and
do this crazy tour of 90 days 23 cities
when i broke my neck and then kept going
on the tour
all of these things that seemed
impossible to me at the time
that then i said i'm gonna do it the
thing that gave me the strength and
courage to do it
is all of the content that i've been
consuming it's the people i've
surrounded myself with who've had
success that make me want to be more
successful myself
and then when you go through these
things when you go through the difficult
journey
when you get faced with something you've
never faced before you come out a
different person
you may not come out like you thought
you would but there's no going back
when you do something difficult went and
did that tour
90 days right a quarter of the year when
i broke my neck and kept going
it changed me for the better
and there's no going back to the person
i was before
and it's the same thing for you if you
are around success on a daily basis
even if only for 10 minutes a day if
you're on success on a daily basis
it will start to seep into you you'll
start to
see the world a different way you'll
start to understand things in a way that
you didn't understand before you'll
start to want more out of life you start
to
not want to settle for what you have in
front of you right now like this is not
enough i want more i gotta get better
and then you'll see opportunities that
you didn't see before but it'll be scary
it'll be different be something that you
haven't tackled before it'll be
something that
the old version of you would be too
afraid to go off and do but for some
reason
this new version of you is willing to at
least try
and through the trial through the effort
through that journey
you come out a totally different person
you've grown
you have new skill sets you're stronger
and that allows you to go off and tackle
another one and another one and another
one
and there's no going back you can't
there's no going back in the mindset
there's no going back in the skill set
there's no going back to that lifestyle
an evolved human now and that's what i
want for you
so i'm going to give you a three-step
process to create that constant push in
your environment
step number one is your physical
environment your physical actual
environment so think about
your your office think about where
you're working think about what's on the
uh the background of your phone think
about what's on
on the background of your desktop think
about what's in your room
when you wake up the physical
environment matters why because
i set this stuff up once right
one time i had to go on i got to think
about who would i want to on my wall and
finding a picture
and then getting that printed and
putting it up that's a one-time thing
take some effort but it's a one-time
thing
what goes on the back of my phone it's a
one-time decision but then
every day it's a reminder it's a trigger
right it's a play
bigger trigger that's what i call it
these pictures are played bigger trigger
for me
this is a play bigger trigger for me so
that you're not even thinking about it
and i walk into my office and bam
i got these people looking at me in the
face now these people may not mean
anything to you
maybe you hate some of these people on
the wall awesome
do it for you whether it's a quote a
picture
a saying nature whatever it is design
your physical environment with intention
that makes you feel bold
powerful and confident you set it up
once and you get to get that feeling
every single day
step two is think about the people
you're surrounded by and these can be
physical people in your life it could be
the people that you're hanging with your
friends your family your co-workers
the sign of a of a dead-end job is
having a boss that that doesn't support
you but going to work
and having a boss that doesn't support
you is the worst
it's the worst feeling of all time you
don't want to be around people
who make you feel less than and so
trying to spend less time with the
people who make you feel less dead
and then think about the people who you
love think about the people who make you
feel energized and pumped up and bold
and confident
and i like to collect good people if i
find someone i like i'll just say i like
you i want to spend more time with you
it feels super awkward and i tell them i
like to collect good people
and that leads somewhere whether that's
a monthly
coffee whether that's a regular phone
call or hangout or workshop like that
that leads places
and so adopt that mindset i want to
eliminate the negative people in my life
or at least limit exposure
and the people who make me feel good i
want to bring them more into my life
i want to find more people who are like
that and the ones who i have i want to
spend more time with
right that's what you should want to do
then there's also the virtual ones
and that's where my series comes in
right the top 10 series of mentor me
series the 254 series
i have 254s around a whole bunch of
different topics around building
confidence
around black excellence around women
entrepreneurship the girl boss series
around self-love around writer's wisdom
and we're building more i want to have a
thousand of these
so that whatever it is that you want to
build more of in your life here it is a
message every single morning
an unlisted free video gets delivered to
your email inbox
that's between one and five minutes
typically so
if you want to be a successful woman
entrepreneur every morning
you get an email with a video of a
successful woman entrepreneur
sharing her wisdom knowledge and advice
if you watch that for 254 days
you will become a different person you
just will you have to sit there and
watch the message
and absorb it and you will come out a
different person maybe not
on a daily daily basis but with time
you watch the videos every day for for
weeks
and then months you will come out a
different person and so whether it's
my videos or something else whether you
need to read part of a book every day
listen to an audio book
get on podcasts whatever it is that
makes you feel bold confident powerful
alive makes you feel like you want to go
off and do something today whatever that
is don't let it happen you by accident
plan for it make it a part of your daily
morning routine
it'll change your life and step number
three is create a powerful morning
routine
it's important here's what i do i got
the five s's here's
here's how i go on a regular basis
number one is sing
i wake up and i'm tired and i've got
stuff in my eyes and lines in my face
i'm i'm tired
and so step number one is i sing i put
on music that makes me sing you all have
music that makes you want to sing the
fastest way to change your state
to change your emotion to change your
confidence is to put on music
don't put on music that makes you feel
more of how you already are if you feel
like you're tired
if you feel down and sad and depressed
and tired don't put on really slow
downing i can't even i can't even think
about it don't don't put on that music
put on the music that you want to feel
so i put on energetic you know songs
that that come on i want to dance and i
want to sing to
that's how you should start your day at
least for me i want to start my day with
singing
step two is sun so sun is i want to get
outside
so we have two dogs and so luckily they
make us go outside every day
but there's just something at least for
me being outside being in nature
not walking out into the forest for two
hours just taking a quick walk around
the neighborhood
with the dogs with my wife it's our
chance to connect there's no electronics
we don't look at our phone yet
it's just a chance to be with each other
enjoy the dogs
we've just had the singing session and
take some sun in
i think if you're around sun and nature
it'll just lift your mood and it's a
great way to start your day
the third s i call sore that's figuring
out the thing that makes you sore as a
human
and doing that in the morning so for me
i think about somebody that i helped
yesterday
i need to be reminded that the work that
i do is important that what i do matters
and so i think about someone i helped
yesterday and then i record a message
on instagram public video 15 seconds
and that that sets me for the day
because so much of what i do is
it's just here in my office talking to a
camera hi guys
that's what i do right this this message
might be reaching
so many people but all i'm doing is
talking into a camera and so
it can be hard when you're working alone
in an office by yourself
to think about the impact the work that
you do has
and so that's what i need to remember
every day i impact people
and not thinking about my goals i hit a
billion entrepreneurs but
but just i helped an individual
yesterday yesterday i helped one person
that meant something to me and how did i
help them whatever that message was
i'm not going to share it with the world
that sets me up for the day
whatever it is it makes you want to soar
you put that into your morning routine
number four is sweat so doing something
every morning
for exercise i i'm slowly getting back
into it because of my neck
injury i have me to be as consistent as
that um so
i'm still doing physio uh let's see that
hurts
but i'm super grateful to not uh be in
my cast and not have to have
spinal surgery which i had a 50 chance
of
possibly having so super grateful for
that but i'm using back into it but if
you can get into the morning
and do something that makes you sweat
it's amazing and the fifth s for me is
scare
so you do something that makes you
scared and so for me it's having a cold
shower
so after you sweat you got a shower so
start off hot and then slowly slowly
slowly get the cold and by the end of it
it's freezing
and that scares me and so if you do
something that scares you every day
i think you come out stronger so that's
my morning routine i do the five s's
right so sing sun sore
sweat and scare go through that five
step process it helps me
but whatever it is that helps you don't
wake up like an accident
don't wake up tomorrow and just check
your phone and respond to everybody
else's emergencies around you
intention start your day with intention
every single day
it'll make a huge difference your
environment has been perfectly designed
to keep you
exactly where you are the people you
hang with the videos you watch the media
you consume all of it
are perfectly designed to keep you
exactly where you
are right now today if you want to raise
your standards
it starts by raising your environment
first
so a friend of mine and friend of the
channel mark drager from fanta
gave me a really warm message yesterday
and he thanked me for helping
start the process for him to turn from
being a pessimist to an optimist from
being somebody who was always worried
and negative
to somebody who's having more energy
who's seen the light who's becoming more
optimistic who still has a road to go
but is
so far further along than where he was
before and he wrote to me to say thank
you for
starting me down this path he said there
was one conversation in particular that
had
special meaning to him where i told him
that i i just really believed in him
that i saw a lot of people around him i
saw a lot of his peers
and i just thought that he had so much
more potential than where he was
and i think maybe for the first time he
had an
extra bolt of belief pushed into him
which is what i do which is what i'm
great at which is what i enjoy doing
fast forward to now six months eight
months later
he's made major gains in his life he's
he's brought on
new team members he's now consuming
other content that is positive
and optimistic he's changing his
business around he's
investing more in himself he's happier
he's lost a lot of weight he's he's
growing he's
wanting to strengthen his relationships
he's just seen a big shift in his life
by trying to move more into optimism
instead of pessimism and so it started
with my conversation with him
he then promoted somebody within his
organization to become
ceo whose name was louis and he's also a
massive force for good and positivity he
started consuming gary's content which
is positivity he started consuming tom
biliu's content which is
positivity he started now injecting all
these these people and resources into
his life
to make him feel more positive more
optimistic more happy give him more
energy
so that he has had to go take on his
goals and the challenges out in front of
him
and slowly move that needle from being a
pessimist
to an optimist i don't think people are
pessimists to be honest i think
everybody
is born an optimist i don't think people
are born
negative you know i think that's trained
into you i think you're pessimistic
negative because
of the circumstances you had and what
was planted in your brain by the people
around you
i think people are good i think humans
are just good i think if we weren't good
we wouldn't be here anymore 99.99999
of people are good right some people
have a little bit of a miswiring up
there and it causes them to enjoy
killing people but
for the most part we're good i also
believe that people are built to serve
i believe that you get happiness from
helping others
by being of service to others that's
what actually makes you happy there
aren't very many happy moments in your
life that didn't involve somebody else
you were helping you were serving
they've shown the effect on your brain
of serving and helping somebody is the
same as food and sex
we're literally hardwired to help others
and to serve
and so if you believe like i believe
that humans are good and humans are
built to serve
then what would cause somebody to be
pessimistic and negative
how sad of an upbringing does that
person have to have had
the programming that was installed
inside them by other people
who just were negative and down on their
life but weren't
inherently bad people the people who
stole from my car in la the guy who cut
me off in traffic yesterday
i don't think they're bad people i still
think they're good people who are built
to serve
just circumstances and conditioning have
led them down a negative path
and so the good news is you can get out
of it just like my friend mark
who was someone who would who was sworn
to say i'm a pessimist
right i just default to negativity
to now seen the shift by changing the
people he surrounded himself with
by altering his environment by consuming
content that is more positive
he's already seen a noticeable shift
over the past x number of months
and that's going to continue to grow
that could be youtube
there's a three-step process here to
follow and i'm going to give it to you
right now
step number one is collect good people
you need to be in the good
people collecting business i had that
conversation with mark that had a
lasting impact on him
because i love mark because in him i see
just
such a good person just so much
potential and i mean i see that in
everybody a lot of potential
but you know i just wanna i wanna
collect good people i want good people
around me i wanna have people
around me in my life who are in my
business or
just associates or just people that i
know that are good people that give me
energy
that that lift me up that i'm excited to
be around
right there are some people that when
you're around you just have more energy
and vibrancy
collect them find ways to work with them
find ways to stay
attached to them i even make it awkward
there's a lot of people who i'll meet if
i meet somebody at a conference or an
event or
or something that's happening in my city
or in another city
if i just really like their energy say i
really like you
i really like you i want to find a way
to do more with you that's awkward
that's hard to say that's weird that's
strange
but chances are they're feeling the same
thing about you
that they don't have as many great
people as they wish they had in their
life as well
and so think about the people who give
you energy that are just good people
that you wish you could spend more time
with them
and tell them that as awkward as that
seems and then find ways to stay around
them more
because you want to have those positive
people in your life
set number two is 254s i've created a
program called 254s
there's a link in this video it's in the
description below where every day for
254 days i send you a video around a
certain topic
in this case is around building
unstoppable confidence if you watch a
video for 254 days
you will become more confident it'll
happen science tells us that it takes
between 18 and 254 days of consecutive
action to build a habit
if you're on a diet for one week it's
likely not to stick it takes at least 18
days
the average is 66 days so most people
don't spend enough time doing the thing
before they quit and give up
but the worst case scenario the slowest
human learner of all time
takes up to 254 days of consecutive
action to build a habit
and so i made the 254 program for you
guys that if you want to have more
confidence so we have a series for women
entrepreneurs or series for
black excellence in a series of writers
right if you if you're a writer
every day for 254 days you're going to
get a free video emailed to you
of a writer who's had success now if
you're a stay-at-home writer you're
trying to
get your first book off the ground you
may not have a lot of people around you
supporting you believing in you
telling you to go for it but then here's
this email every day with a new video
from somebody who's made it giving you
an inspirational message that's
30 seconds to five minutes long right my
goal ultimately is to have a thousand of
these
i wanna have a thousand two fifty fours
because you may not care about the
writer's wisdom program
if you're not a writer you may care
about the confidence one if you want
go to the description and find the link
to get on but if not then make your own
like make your own
even this channel spreads believe every
day if you want to have more believe in
your life
watch these videos that's the intent it
spreads believe if you feel a little bit
more belief in yourself that you are a
genius
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
if this video helps spark that then then
watch more
and if it's not me then it's somebody
else go watch gary's content go watch
tony's content go watch mel's content
whoever it is
create your own 254 program or every day
for 254 days at least
ultimately becomes a lifetime thing
you're surrounding yourself with with
resources
that feeds the positivity in your mind
that hope
that the things are possible that you
don't need to stay where you are right
now
that you can end up in a better place if
you put in the work
but if you don't believe that it's
possible you won't chase it down so you
need to create your own 254 program
and then number three is have play
bigger triggers play bigger triggers are
things in your environment that remind
you to step
up it could be a shirt that you wear
right and that shirt that you put on
reminds you to play a bigger game it
could be your physical environment
putting up posters or banners in your
office wherever you're working or in
your car
as a reminder that you need to step up
it could be your screen time right
what's on your cell phone background
what's on your desktop background
that when you look at every day reminds
you it's triggers in your environment to
step
up and play a bigger game your
environment is keeping you where you are
so you need to change your environment
doesn't mean that you can afford
necessarily to move out and go buy some
penthouse in new york city that looks
over central park
right that may not happen but you can
have a poster of it
as a reminder that you're building a
better future that this is not where
you're going to be
this place that you're in right now is
not going to be where you're going to be
in a year
because you're making big growth you're
making big gains
and so you want to set up triggers in
your environment that remind you
constantly
why it's beautiful is you set it up once
you set up your cell phone background
once
and what it does is reminds you every
time you look at your phone how many
times are you looking at your phone
would you like an inspirational message
to remind you to play bigger something
emotional has to mean something to you
don't copy what i have these are my
parents
it means something to me to have them on
the wall my parents on your wall won't
mean very much probably
right it's a little weird so what are
the things what is your environment what
is your home office what is what's in
your car what's in your bedroom what's
on the cell phone in your computer
background what is it what are the
things that
when you see just makes you think that's
right and it snaps you out of mediocrity
it snaps you out of the way you are
because
you want to just stay where you are
again it's been perfectly designed to
keep you where you are it's easy to stay
where you are
and then bam something shows up so you
could trick yourself
you can force yourself to play a bigger
game if you set up the right play bigger
triggers for yourself
this is why i keep going with my youtube
channel this is the reason why i keep
going with my youtube channel because
yes your spouse is important and yes
your friend's important and the people
that you hang out with
are super super super important and
all the other people that you hang out
with by reading books and consuming
content watching videos
all of that makes an impact too the more
that you spend
hanging around people and ideas and
wisdom that bring you up
the more you're going to rise up and the
more you're around people who are
complaining and negative and pulling you
down
guess what happens the more you're gonna
be pulled down
and one of the big reasons for me in
creating this channel was i wanted to be
around
successful entrepreneurs i wanted to be
around people who would push me to go
off and do more
because in my life i'm super fortunate
to have a very understanding
wife a very supportive family friends
who
encourage me and you know always support
the things that i'm doing
but i don't have people who are pushing
me to do better you know i don't have
people who say you know what
what you're doing is great but you
should be out here like
you could be making these adjustments
and playing a bigger game you can have a
bigger impact
and so i needed more of that in my life
and so my solution to finding it was
was the videos was i want to hang around
elon musk and i want to hang around
steve jobs i want to hang around
warren buffet i want to hang around
these people who are thinking on a
bigger scale because the more you do
that
the more you ingest this content the
more you're going to think like them the
more you're going to act like them the
more you're gonna
pick these pieces to not only just be
like them but to be the best version of
you
i think what most people do is we we try
to escape a life that we don't like
we watch big brother on tv we watch
these reality shows we like
laughing at somebody else's faults and
mistakes we're constantly you know
looking at
facebook and instagram and looking at
the negativity of people
you know hating each other we like
watching fail videos you know
we like escaping our life there's
something about our lives that we don't
like and so we want to escape it
why do people want to go on vacations
all the time well it's not because they
actually want to go there it's more they
want to
escape a life that they don't like and
there's nothing wrong with traveling
it's a great time to
get experiences meet new people think
outside the box
but it shouldn't just be an escape from
a life that you don't like and that's
where most people spend their time
use that time instead to do the
uncomfortable thing
to grow to build muscle right to
challenge yourself
to look towards a life that you want to
live
by surrounding yourself with the people
who push you to think differently
to do the uncomfortable things to grow
to go outside your comfort zone right to
do that scary thing that you want to do
that you think is too bold too bad
too big who am i to go off and do that
you know the more you spend time around
these successful people
the bolder you're going to be the more
confidence you're going to have and the
bigger
impact you're going to be able to go out
and create and so it's one of the
foundational reasons why
i still do these youtube videos why i
love it so much why i'm still
invested so much into the regular
creation of this content because
it's awesome that it helps you it helps
me
like i need it i need to push i need
elon musk kicking my butt
i need to watch that stuff and realize
you know what i'm still playing small
i'm working harder than most of the
people that i know and
i need to be doing more you know i need
to be thinking on a bigger scale i need
to have
greater ambitions because i believe if
you have the ability
then you have the responsibility if you
can then you must
and i know that i can and i'm not doing
enough and i know that you can
and you're not doing enough either and
so the people that you surround yourself
are really important
yes the people in your life yes your
spouse is super important
yes the friends that you choose to
surround yourself with some people
you may not have an option you know your
family may not be supportive
you can limit exposure but you may not
have an option they're still your family
you haven't chosen them
but the rest of your time like you're
not spending 24
7 with your family the rest of the time
you get to choose
and are you choosing to just escape a
life that you don't like
and watching content that numbs your
mind
or you choosing to move in a forward
direction make your life better
the difference in people is their
standards
the world is full of people who started
with less than what you already have
right now
and they're winning and too many people
are out there complaining
complaining that you don't have the
money that you don't have the time that
you don't have the experience that you
don't have the
personality for it all legitimate
logical reasons but others have done it
with those very same circumstances as
you with
worse circumstances than you the
difference is
they have a higher standard for
themselves and today
we're gonna raise yours one of the
things i'm most proud about for myself
why do i love evan carmichael is because
when i say i'm gonna do something
i do it especially when it gets hard
like it doesn't count until it gets hard
and i'm doing it not just for other
people i'm doing it and that's because i
promised you that i would show up i'm
doing it for myself because i said i was
going to do something
and then i go off and do it this is the
foundation of self-esteem
a self-confidence of self-love doing it
when you say you're gonna do it
and so on monday i usually have a
two-hour
walk-in meeting with alex alex help
someone trying to down salsa
he comes over monday's my mentoring day
and we'll usually go for a two-hour walk
around the city and it's starting to get
cold you know it's winter time here it's
getting cold
and so we bundle up and we go for our
two hour walk while we while we talk and
while we meet
i'm trying to do walking meetings more
just for my own health and
and just because just for the challenge
of it because it's easy to start
something like that
in the spring or in the summer it's
really hard to do it when it's in the
winter and you live in toronto canada
and it's snowing and cold
right so this monday alex was sick
he still came in he was sick he was
running a bit of a fever not crazy sick
but
just sick and nina my wife super karen
said hey maybe you shouldn't go for
a walk outside and and in my heart just
like come on
no we have to i said i was gonna do it
right i have to
i have to for myself i have to go on the
walk like i'll go on the walk and leave
alex at my place and
and just film the meeting with him uh
but we came up with a different solution
which was
i have a i live in a condo we have a gym
in my condo and we went down to the
condo gym and i walked on the treadmill
while he stood or sat next to me for two
hours
because i said that i was gonna do it
how important is that one
two hour walk not much right in itself
not much
am i gonna get healthy from doing that
one walk no am i gonna
lose weight by doing that one walk no
i'm gonna have so much more mental
clarity by doing that one walk of course
not
but it's the whole game because you're
teaching yourself that you follow
through you're teaching yourself that
you have high standards you're teaching
yourself that when you say you're going
to do something
you follow through because life is
coming for you with a ton of roadblocks
life is going to throw tons of curve
balls at you if you can only do the
thing that you said you were going to do
when it's easy and the path is perfectly
clear you're never going to do it this
is why people don't stay consistent
because as soon as life gets hard you
let yourself off the hook
you allow your standards to drop to say
oh it's okay yeah of course i can't go
for a walk cause alex is sick
right and there are definitely
legitimate times when you should let
yourself off the hook if i was dying in
bed
with a fever and i couldn't get out of
bed i wouldn't go for the walk that
makes sense
don't be stupid there's times when you
need to be gentle on yourself but more
often than not
we are too gentle on ourselves when we
shouldn't be i could have done the walk
and we did it we did it in the in the in
the gym downstairs and alex
stood next to me and sat next to me and
didn't have to go outside and
and get the cold on him and i still got
my lock walk-in
right and i feel great about it because
i did it when it was hard because here's
this obstacle that life's thrown at me
here's an
easy way when everybody around me saying
you don't have to go off and do it
and a little tiny voice inside my own
head saying okay well here's a chance
you don't have to do it like no
be quiet voice i'm doing it we're
finding a solution let's go
and the solution is going to walk on the
treadmill downstairs if you want to sign
up for the entire billionaire mindset
series for free and get the companion
bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there